could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
am i doing everything in my power to
live the way i want to live because if
it could be over in a moment i got to
shift my attention to things that really
matter our next guest has quite a resume
a former professional football player
turned lifestyle entrepreneur who was
making millions of dollars in helping
others achieve their dreams new york
times best-selling author school of
greatness please welcome lewis you have
been very very open about the abuse you
suffered when you were five i mean i
knew something was wrong i knew
something was off every single day for
25 years i thought about it i needed to
heal the memories of the past in order
to create a
healthy relationship with myself and
others in the present the challenge is
most men have not been taught how to
effectively communicate their guilt
their insecurities
constantly working on yourself is huge
in intimacy in relationships what is the
single biggest killer of relationships
i'm gonna say something right now that
you're probably not gonna like
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
lewis
i have to start with a with a point of
gratitude which is thank you so much for
doing this you are and i don't say this
lightly but you are one of the real
inspirations for me in this whole
podcasting content space because you've
been you're like the goat in my eyes
you've you're the guy that did it first
in in our space and did it best at the
same time but not just that when i got
to meet you maybe a month ago in dubai i
was pretty much in awe of a bunch of
things that i noticed about you that
really set you apart one of them was
this real
unbelievable self-awareness which i
talked to my team about before you got
here i said he's one of the most
self-aware guys that i've ever met
because he's done and doing the work and
the second thing is there's actually
probably three things that come to mind
the second thing is your genuine
curiosity about humans on a very
deep level because we'd be having we
were having a conversation at 2 a.m in a
bar and if there was a moment of silence
it would be interjected by you with like
a tell me three things that you're your
biggest failings in life or three things
and i just thought
this is a guy that doesn't want to mess
around at surface level with small talk
and things that don't matter and then
the third point which kind of links to
those two in some way is your
unbelievable ability to speak and
deliver a concept or an idea with wisdom
and a personal anecdote attached in a
way that's captivating to the point that
people don't tune out when you're
talking and i don't i'm not blowing
smoke up your ass but i genuinely was
like i need to learn this
specifically that delivery of ideas and
having seen you on jay's and tom bill
used podcasts i saw it then again and
it's a culmination of all that
self-awareness and practice but there
was something else which you
showed me when we were in dubai having
that conversation at 2 am in the morning
which is where i wanted to start our
conversation today which was the the
screen saver of your phone
that really stayed with me yeah
can you tell me what the screensaver of
your phone is
this is uh yeah i don't know if you guys
for those watching on youtube i don't
know if you guys can see this but this
is a photo of myself uh when i'm
probably about five years old
and
i put it on there a year ago because i
was doing some intensive
i would say inner child healing with a
therapist i was working in in a in
another relationship that i was ending i
was ending a relationship and i realized
that in relationships
in the past i was repeating a pattern of
people pleasing of saying yes to things
that i didn't want to say yes to of
changing and shifting who i
authentically was in order to try to
please or make someone else happy
and a lot of it came from the dynamics
of my childhood from being sexually
abused from having just
a challenging let's say family dynamic
with parents and things like that and so
for years i was never taught on how to
deal with my
inner child
i never was taught how to
heal the things that i was really
wounded as a child and so
having these experiences of intensive
emotional intelligence and therapy
training
on dealing with previous relationships
and then in the current relationship
was extremely helpful for me and my my
therapist said we got to heal that part
of your life
that is attached to a memory of a wound
and unless you heal that you're to keep
repeating certain patterns and so that's
why i have that on there and i'm
actually going to change it to a
different
period of time in my life when i was
about 11 to 12.
that's the next phase of growth for me
is to actually heal that next stage
so that's why i do it what was the world
and the perception of the world that
that five-year-old lewis house saw and
felt what was he feeling and seeing
oh man
he was abandoned he was abused he was
taken advantage of he was unworthy he
was unlovable
and that was what i believed
and so it's hard to create
a meaningful
relationship with myself and with
another person
if that story or narrative or belief was
still there for me which it was
unconsciously so i needed to heal the
memories of the past in order to create
a
healthy relationship with myself and
others in the present
and where did that story come from that
he was unlovable i've heard you describe
yourself even as thinking you were dumb
thinking you you couldn't
you weren't worthy of friendships and
things like that where did all of that
i mean it was all from
real life experiences and results that i
was experiencing so
just getting picked on as a kid feeling
neglected from parents and family
members feeling you know again sexual
abuse that i dealt with
and struggling throughout school my
entire childhood until it took me seven
years to finish college i was in the
bottom of my class in school
elementary middle and high school
and so the narrative was there were real
world results that were showing me that
i was unlovable or being taken advantage
of or abused or these things
and so that stayed with me and this is
why i built a persona
or really a mask i tried to mask it and
defend myself by becoming a great
athlete by getting bigger faster and
stronger so that i could defend myself
against the feeling of being taken
advantage of or abused but that didn't
leave me feeling fulfilled it left me
feeling angry and resentful
when you were you you
have been very very open about the abuse
you suffered when you were five from a
babysitter's son i believe yeah
did you understand at the time that it
was abuse
no i had no idea i mean i knew something
was wrong i knew something was off
but i didn't know i mean as a
five-year-old i don't think anyone
really knows how to
emotionally handle that or emotionally
regulate or understand what's really
happening at that time
but it was something that i lived with
for
every single day for 25 years i thought
about it i thought about the instant
whether it be consciously or
unconsciously it was coming up it might
be a second or it might be minutes long
of a memory but it came up pretty much
every every day for 25 years until
i went through it a
transformational workshop experience
that got me to finally face it and it
wasn't until i faced it
and started to integrate the healing of
that moment that
i felt like i was a prisoner for so long
until it set me free of actually talking
about my shame expressing it
communicating it with my friends my
family and then eventually i did a
podcast about it
which took me about six months to
publish because i recorded it and i
waited six months because i said if
people knew this about me no one would
love me my business is over
i'm gonna have no friends if people
actually knew how shameful
this thing was for me and i think that
was the biggest fear but what i realized
this was back in 2013
i mean the end of 2013 early 2014.
and i thought my i literally thought my
life was over i was like no one is gonna
love me but i i also thought to myself
i can no longer be a prisoner inside
with this information i need to let it
out
and if i can help one man
heal from what they've been through then
it's worth it i'm happy to lose
everything if i can help one man
and it was one of the most
profound experiences and and really
spiritually freeing experiences of my
life was opening up talking about it and
the aftermath was so powerful
for weeks i was getting essays from men
opening up saying
you know i'm married i've got three kids
i'm 55.
my wife and kids don't know and i've
been holding this with me for this long
it happened to me when i was 11. you
know men opening up about all the
different experiences of sexual abuse or
trauma that they face with
the challenge is most men have not been
taught how to effectively communicate
their shame their guilt their
insecurities
there's not many guys that grow up i
don't think you had guy friends when you
were 12 15 18 23 saying you know what
can we just have a coffee and talk about
how shameful i feel about my
my uh my past right now or i don't only
feel that good today let's talk about it
or my body image is kind of off like we
don't do that generally as men we're not
taught how to do that in society but
when you ask women
how often do you meet with a girlfriend
on a weekly basis to talk about your
shame your insecurities the challenges
you're dealing with in your
relationships
struggles at work
whatever it might be
women typically say they they meet with
their girlfriends every week if not
every single day they'll have a
conversation with a girlfriend a sister
a mom about a challenge or just what's
on their mind
but we just haven't been taught that so
i started i really wanted to change the
narrative
and be a model
there was no one that looked like me
growing up that talked about these
things there was no athlete that i
admired that was like on tv saying i've
been sexually abused or i went through
childhood trauma or i didn't love myself
or i struggled with insecurities growing
up i just didn't see that growing up as
a kid
so my goal was to be a model of saying
you know i'm willing to lose everything
if i can help men heal because i truly
believe
a lot of the pain caused in the world is
caused by men who have massive wounds
who are reactive because they don't know
how to handle
or regulate their emotions and so they
react in certain scenarios whether it be
domestic violence domestic abuse war
uh just reactions on social media
causing more stress screaming in a
workplace whatever it might be
driving here in london just people
honking at the horn because they're they
don't know how to handle their inner
wounds their emotional regulation
and i feel like if all humans but men
specifically can continue to learn these
tools it'll be powerful
but we weren't taught this in school
there was nothing in school that was
like
okay emotional regulation 101 class
there was none of this it was just suck
it up be a man toughen up
don't you know we don't talk about these
things so
and i think the world has been shifting
over the last four or five years as well
where it's more acceptable for men to
talk about it with
you know social media in a good sense
allowing men to be more vulnerable and
kind of lifting these conversations up
about mental health so
i'm seeing that shift but i just didn't
see that or have a model when i was
growing up in terms of models when you
were growing up could you tell me a
little bit about the dynamics of your
parents as well because i've heard you
describe the early life
and um
yeah the quote that i read from you was
that they were miserable times and the
tension in the house impacted
you and your siblings yeah i mean
i grew up
it's challenging because my father just
passed away a month and a half ago and
for 17 years he
he got in an accident 17 years ago with
a car accident where a car came up on
his car hit him through the windshield
and split his head open he was in a coma
for a few months
had severe brain trauma stayed alive
miraculously but just had a challenging
17 years where he never fully recovered
so it was a it was an interesting
dynamic with my dad the last 17 years
growing up as the youngest of four
my siblings i feel like probably had it
worse than me
they had to deal with you know 20 year
old
parents my parents were 20 when they had
my brother and then 24 when they had my
sister and then 28 when they had my
other sister then they had me at 31.
so they had to deal you know grow up
with parents who didn't have these tools
either so i have a lot of grace for my
parents because they didn't have the
tools of emotional regulation or how to
communicate effectively or how to
process wounds and i think if you don't
know how to process wounds it's going to
be hard to just interact
without being defensive or reactive or
you know all these different things
passive aggressive
so i grew up for the first 13 years of
my life
in fear
in fear
i knew my parents loved me but there was
this like energy that felt fearful and i
was afraid of my father
he was pretty angry he was an angry guy
and he
would he was super loving but then he
would explode at times because he didn't
know how to process emotions
and he had wounds and so that was the
challenging thing it was it was
confusing and they weren't
loving towards each other so i didn't
feel safe
my brother went away to prison when i
was eight years old for for four and a
half years so every weekend we would
travel two years two hours to go to a
prison visiting room and see my brother
for a few hours so i was exposed to
things that i probably shouldn't have
been exposed to at eight years old until
12
which expanded my mind and my my my
world view and my perception of people
but also it's just challenging to have a
sibling in jail for that long and
dealing with the dynamics of that
yeah it was just a
it was a challenging time but at 13
i begged my parents to send me away i
went to a private boarding school at 13
uh from middle school and high school
and
i couldn't get away fast enough they
didn't send me away because i was a bad
kid i begged them to send me away
because i didn't feel safe at home i
really want to dig into that what was it
your dad's anger
and his anger directed i guess uh
you or your siblings or all of us yeah
all of us but it wasn't all the time you
know so again he was a loving guy he
would tuck me into bed at night he would
play catch with me in the backyard but
then there'd be but then it'd be an
explosion
and we just didn't know when it would be
and so the beautiful part about my dad
is he had a massive transformation when
i turned 13. he started to dive into the
emotional intelligence training
workshops and and seeking
wisdom on how to process his emotions
and he had incredible you know healing
transformation so from 13 to 21 i had
this incredible relationship with my dad
he would fly out to all my games he
would be so loving and supportive he
wasn't angry he wasn't reactive he had
this transformation so it's almost like
i had two lives with my dad the first
half of first 13 years
i loved him but i was also afraid of him
13 to 21 he was like my best friend and
so when he got in his accident when i
was around 21.
it was devastating because now i didn't
have a mentor that now was showing up in
a different way was loving was
vulnerable i saw him cry a lot more i
saw him just be sensitive
so when he got his accident i didn't
have that anymore he wasn't able to have
that relationship with me because of the
brain accident
and this was a time when i felt like i
needed it the most right i went to go
play arena football
i went to go chase a dream i got injured
in at the end of the first season had a
surgery with my wrist
and
at that time was 2000 end of 2007 2008
the economy was crashing in usa
people weren't hiring
those who had master's degrees i barely
graduated with a you know just a general
degree
i'm living on my sister's couch for a
year and a half i've got no money i've
got no mentorship from my father
and so in a sense
it was almost like
this is the weird thing when i reflect
back on it because
i don't think i would be the man i am
today without his accident although i
wish he didn't have the accident
i don't think i'd be in service i don't
think i would care about people as much
i don't think i'd be on a mission to
want to change lives and serve millions
of people around the world i don't think
it'd be doing an interview show or a
podcast i don't think you'd be writing
books or all these things
but something shifted within me
because he was physically alive but
emotionally and mentally not there so i
didn't have that access to a
relationship
something shifted in me where i couldn't
rely on him for money for kind of that
wisdom
i had to
i just had to unleash something new
that was that i didn't think was inside
of me and i don't know if your parents
are still around or if your dad is still
oh yeah yeah
something shifted in me 17 years ago
when
my dad got in the accident and then
something shifted even more in the last
month and a half when he passed
that it's hard to explain i don't know i
haven't really fully processed it it's
still kind of a processing time
and there's some a lot of gratitude and
memories but a lot of sadness tied to it
but i just don't think i'd be the man i
am without his accident because it made
me unleash something inside of me that
was untapped when i met you in dubai
every topic you talked on you talked on
as if you'd processed it and done work
on it and you had a perspective on it
and then when you spoke about your dad
it was
like the end of what we call a
cul-de-sac getting to the end of the
street where there's nowhere else to go
it was like you hadn't the conversation
ended there
and you would look down at the floor
yeah and i knew i'm so sorry to hear of
your loss by the way but i could see
that it was still something that you're
like there was two kind of suspicions i
had one was that
you you were still processing it of
course yeah but the second was that
there was a profound lesson somewhere
there because of the pause you took and
the way that you looked at the floor and
but on every other topic you were like
illuminated it's the best way to
describe it you see what i mean yeah i
think one of the things that it taught
me 17 years ago was that
my dad also felt larger than life i
don't know if your father felt that way
it feels that way as well yeah but he
felt large in life he was extremely
intelligent and smart
he was
a very charismatic he was
resourceful talented he was
he he was a big lover he loved people
and he gave his heart in a big way after
this transformation
and he cared deeply about relationships
like i witnessed things he did that
brought smiles to people's faces all the
time
which is probably a lot of things that
i've like translated in my own life but
one of the things that taught me was
that if this can happen to a guy who
feels larger than life in a moment when
he was on vacation with his then uh you
know partner at the time not my mother
they got divorced but they were on
vacation having a great time if this
could happen in a moment
at any time
then it brought so much urgency to my
life to make sure i pursue the things
that really are meaningful to me
and for years there were things that i
had to do that i wasn't like love i had
to work really hard to get to that place
when i was broke and had no money on my
sister's couch it wasn't like this all
just unfolded perfectly it was years of
effort work late nights all that stuff
but it made me just say what is my
mission what's my intention for this
season of my life and am i doing
everything in my power to live the way i
want to live because if it could be over
in a moment
i got to shift my attention to things
that really matter and so that was a big
powerful shift for me and when he passed
last month
it made it even clearer you know there's
so many
opportunities for someone like yourself
and myself at this stage of our life and
our careers
and a lot of opportunities can seem
incredible here's a big money-making
opportunity here's a cool project i can
do with someone here's these things that
are coming my way
but if it's not aligning to
my mission of something greater
if it's not aligning to my ultimate
level of joy and authentic power then
should i be doing it right now if it was
all over in a day and a month in a year
is this something i would say yes to and
so it's just bringing me closer to that
awareness
that how it could all be over in a
moment and it brings the energy back to
like my relationship with my girlfriend
i'm like
if it was over tomorrow am i doing and
saying what i need to say today and
that's been a powerful thing for me
there's a real
i mean i always reflect on this that
brony ware who was the palliative nurse
who interviewed people in their last
days and the retrospective clarity
people must have in their last days
about what they did and didn't do yeah
right is so so empowering but as you say
there one of the things that terrifies
me is my dad is ill he's like not in
good health and he's
he's outlived his siblings and his life
if you look at it in any kind of
comparative measure was way more
stressful than them and his brother died
of a heart attack and his brother died
younger than he is now so this thing is
haunting me almost in the back room
and the haunting thing is like what
should i be doing now my relationship
with my dad isn't particularly strong
um you know what i mean
how often do you see them a year
through
three four times okay
this my friend jesse etzler made this
example one time to me
uh and to like the audience he said
and his father just passed away actually
a couple weeks ago
and he said my my parents are old
they're in their 80s or something like
that and um you know maybe they have
five or ten more years but it's really
five or ten more times with them if you
only see them once or twice a year it's
not five or ten years if you see them
two three times a year
maybe you have three times if it's a
year maybe you have ten times if it's
four years that you experienced a moment
in person with your dad
yeah hopefully he lives 10 20 years but
two to three times a year is really 20
times left
with your dad
and when we put it in i just got chills
thinking about that when we put it in
perspective like that are we
giving as much as we could to the
relationship
are we
opening up and healing certain things
that maybe aren't aren't healed yet are
we having the conversations that are
unspoken and i think
i feel like i did the best of my
abilities to do that with where he was
at emotionally and mentally
and i would encourage you or anyone
listening or watching to
to ask themselves on a scale of one to
ten how is my relationship with my
father my mother
and
if it's not above a seven
right now
what can you do not about them even if
they're the parent what can you do
to
reach out and communicate
how can you take responsibility for your
part of that relationship
and you just never know in any moment
what if someone's not listening to this
now and they think well my parents or my
dad or my mum or whatever was abusive or
toxic or whatever to me is
i think you got to ask yourself if they
died today would i be happy with how i
communicated how i showed up
and maybe that means you need to disown
your parents for a season of life
because you're not able to get along
but are you still happy if you did that
with everything you tried to do from a
loving calm
healed place it's your healing journey
it's not about what they do or what they
didn't do it's about your healing
journey and i look at it as a gift from
everything i experience from my
childhood you know i don't look at it as
a painful thing anymore you know i'm not
living in fear from the memories of my
past anymore i look at it as god i'm so
grateful that i grew up
feeling insecure unlovable
and really dumb
because i care deeply about loving other
people i care deeply about
being a good listener and showing people
how much i care
i care deeply about wisdom and knowledge
in a different way not just from school
and books but from interactions with
human experiences adventure learning new
skills and hobbies
and just progressing as a human
and i think
you know even from the sexual abuse i'm
not mad at it anymore i'm not hurt by it
anymore
i hope it never happens to anyone in the
history i don't wish it on anyone but i
also know that it gave me an incredible
gift because
i've healed from it i've taken my power
back from that
and i know that it's benefited me now
because i've rewrote in the story
about what it means about me and i think
if we can rewrite those stories in an
empowering way then we are not powerless
we're powerful
to that point of your healing journey
though
you describe your life in these three
sort of sections right you've got the i
think it's the the preteens yeah and
then it's like the team to 22 and then
it's the
is it for and then the 20s and then the
30s right yeah the 20s phase as i read
it as i read through the whole all the
experiences on you you know your
sister's sofa the linkedin stuff you've
done felt a little bit like you were
finding yourself yeah of course yeah and
then post 30s
it's it feels like the work really
started to begin i mean 30 is when
everything started to change because
that's the moment
i allowed myself to be vulnerable for
the first time i just thought i had it
figured out and what i realized is i
knew nothing there were symptoms
of an internal conflict that suggested
to you that you didn't have it figured
out of course yeah
i mean
i mean getting in fist fights on a
basketball court in a in a pickup game
that's supposed to be fun and reacting
so much to
someone jabbing me you know in the ribs
or or smack talking me talking bad or
just like talking trash and being so
reactive
she's getting it like you're
extremely explosive
again it was more of like i didn't heal
a lot of things from my childhood it
wasn't like one thing for my dad or the
sexual abuse it was kind of like
the entire childhood all the stories and
all the examples that made me feel like
i'm not lovable or i'm someone to be
taken advantage of
was still inside of me so it wasn't just
one thing or one experience it was all
of it that was building a case for me to
be reactive and explosive and feel like
uh you know the
the world was just out to get me or
something
and when i learned
the art of emotional regulation that's
when everything started to change and i
learned a part of that at 30
until 37
but in intimate relationships i still
hadn't learned how to
fully love and honor my authentic power
i still gave in because i deeply wanted
people to like me i deeply wanted the
person that i was giving my heart to
to love and accept me
and yet i was choosing people
based on a wound still from
my parents
from my mom you know
giving in from my mom not feeling
probably loved and accepted and kind of
repeating that pattern of her
with my dad i was finding
partners like that and i was
taking on the mother role
like kind of what my mom was taking on
and i was giving in i watched her give
in over and over and over to my dad and
never stand up for who she truly was
you know this is all unconscious it
wasn't until about a year ago when i
started to learn this and process it
so i was choosing partners
that after a period of time
they would get upset at me over and over
of lots of different things they just
weren't happy with who i was or the
actions or decisions or
things i did in my business or whatever
whatever it was that made them feel like
they were
insecure or something same
and so i would say okay
i'll change this to make you happy okay
you don't like me doing this okay i'll
stop doing this okay you don't like me
salsa dancing you don't like me
traveling you don't like me speaking you
don't like me doing okay like whatever's
gonna make you happy because there was
love there and i thought
that when you love someone you'll do
whatever you can to make that love
stay to make it last and so i would give
and give and give
up who i was in order to create peace
and love
and what i was doing was creating
incredible pain
resentment and anger and frustration was
inside of me of the person
of the relationship and of myself
because you were abandoning yourself
abandoning myself over and over again
and i didn't know how to say no
and how how to
be around someone who was unhappy with
me in intimacy i could do this in
business and friends but in intimacy
when there was love
i didn't know how to say no and so i
just gave in to create peace
and what i realized is that
you know i was looking to create to buy
peace by abandoning myself but you can't
buy peace
we must be peace
and if someone is okay with that great
if they're not then maybe you're not in
alignment
and that's okay but i was not willing to
let go of the feeling of love it was a
false love it wasn't authentic love
because authentic love is accepting the
person for who they are
and them accepting you for who you are
it's not trying to change the person if
you're trying to change someone you
shouldn't be with them we should be
elevating each other to grow but if
there are fundamental things about you
that i don't like
and i'm trying to change you why am i in
a relationship with you go find someone
that you don't need to change
and vice versa and so my girlfriend
martha i was like listen
we started dating and i'd done
months of this healing work and finally
started the process and feel this inner
peace i said listen i'm going to be 100
authentic to who i am i'm going to
obnoxiously be myself around you and i'm
letting you know i want to i want to be
so obnoxiously myself
that i i hope you run away i hope you
run away because
i'm never going to change i'm not going
to change for you or anyone else i'm
going to evolve i'm going to constantly
improve grow
i want you to be willing to give me
feedback but i'm not going to change
of something you're unhappy about about
me
here are my values here's my vision
here's my lifestyle this is what i'm
going to be doing i'm not going to
change this stuff just letting you know
and it's been a beautiful journey
because it's amazing just to see what
it's like having authentic trust and
someone receiving you for a hundred
percent who you are and feeling like i
can be myself i've never felt this until
now it's beautiful
it's such a
important conversation because it's
crazy man you described the reasons why
in your trauma that that made you a
people pleaser and do you know what's
really interesting is when you told me
that you were a people pleaser
um i couldn't believe that i'm like what
you big tough athlete man people pleaser
carrick you know what i mean but it just
it goes to show that that sort of that
trauma in us yeah um
is kind of agnostic to to our mask or
absolutely you know certain
and i when you told me that because we
had a little bit of this conversation
just a hint of it in when we met in
dubai
i realized that i've been a people
please actually but i never thought i
was in all of my relationships i think
the significant reason why they failed
is exactly what you've described i've
gone in trying to compromise everything
really oh my god
just just to keep them and try and keep
them happy um with me and in the short
term that day fine
you go any kind of mid to long term time
horizon and it's resentment
you know i take full responsibility for
every relationship i've chosen and been
in and stayed in
because
i could have gone out of any
relationship at any moment
but i was afraid and i lacked the
really the self-confidence to step away
because i was afraid of losing love
but it's not real love if it's
inauthentic if you're having to change
who you are to make someone happy i just
don't feel like that's real love
i'm all for
making adjustments in alignment with
certain things but it shouldn't be
changing your core essence of who you
are to make someone happy that's not
real love
you said something to me which um really
puzzled me because i've never heard it
before which was when i said um i
started talking to you about what things
i should be compromising in my
relationships and you went no compromise
i mean
for me i don't believe in compromising
who i am
yeah if you're like listen
this week i want to go to this place for
a restaurant and next week you can
choose that's i guess a compromise of
like activities yeah yeah but not
compromising your core values and your
authentic power if we are compromising
our authentic selves
we are essentially saying
screw you to our creator you've created
us for who we are and no i don't want to
be this way for one human being because
it doesn't make them feel good or makes
them unhappy or they're afraid or scared
as opposed to who can i be
if i'm 100 myself in life
and i'm not saying like if you've got
flaws
adjust those and prove those like i'm
all willing to improve and adjust all my
flaws but if it's something that's at my
core is my personality i'm not changing
for anyone
why i want to be changing for one person
that just doesn't seem like a good i
don't know situation and i've done it
for too long and with with martha your
current partner yeah um you had a
conversation very early on about your
unwillingness to compromise your core
values yes and my priorities and your
priorities yes
so tell me exactly what you mean by your
priorities yeah how that was received
man i told her probably like three
months in as we
i knew in the first night i met her i go
i wanted to be single i was like just
got done this healing journey get out of
a relationship i was like i really want
to be single for like a year and just be
single
and i met her
before that time and i remember thinking
uh crap there's something unique and
special here on a different level more
than just
sexual attraction there's a spiritual
connection there's something deeper that
i can see a vision of something
incredible
that i couldn't do on my own right
and i was like let me just string this
along as far as i can before i get
committed right let me just give it some
space not jump into this thing too fast
like let's just take it slow
and after about three months i said to
her i go listen i'm gonna tell you
something that i don't think you're
gonna like and i said this many times to
her i go i'm gonna say something right
now that you're probably not gonna like
and i don't think any woman wants to
hear this from a man i'm just letting
you know and she's thinking i'm about to
drop a bomb or something and i'm like
you may not want to continue dating me
after you hear this
she was like what is it you know she's
freaking out
i go
you will never be my number one priority
never
and i had an explanation i said listen
my number one priority needs to be my
health
because without my health i can't fully
show up for my number two priority which
is my mission or my calling from god oh
god he wasn't even number two louis and
i said you're not number one and you're
not number two
you're number three
and no woman wants to hear i'm the third
priority in some man's life they need to
make me number one i need to be thinking
they need to think about me all the time
i'm number one priority otherwise i'm
out of here
and it's not that she's not a number one
top priority but health needs to come
first
at all times that doesn't mean all day
i'm doing my health it's just i need to
make sure every day i'm taking care of
it this is a top priority if this is
number two number three number 10 i'm
not going to be good for you in our
relationship i'm not going to have
energy i'm going to be more
moody so i need to make this a priority
first
for the second priority which is my
mission my calling from god the universe
the world whatever you want to call
whatever's speaking through me
into the existence because if that is
not a high priority for me then i'm
going to be unhappy because i'm gonna
feel like there's something calling me
in the world and i'm not doing it
because i'm giving more time and
attention
to one person
but if i'm healthy
and working on myself if i am putting
energy and time into my mission
then you're going to have the most
incredible relationship of your life
because i'm going to be of service to
you in such a high beautiful authentic
way
that you're going to be feeling like
you're the number one priority
but you just have to be an awareness
that this is where i'm coming from and
it doesn't mean i'm not going to be
spending all my time with you and i'm
free and we're not going to have an
amazing life
but you got to be aware this is my
priorities and the crazy thing is
right when i finished she said that's
the most amazing thing i've ever heard
because that's exactly what i've been
looking for
i've been dating guys with no purpose
none of them had a purpose they made me
their purpose
and i was like no what's the thing you
want to do in the world what's the
calling you have and none of them had a
calling
they had stuffed activities they had
hobbies but it wasn't like a main
calling in the world
and she was like you're the perfect
match for me
because you have a mission to serve the
world and i'm cool with that were you
trying to scare her off in a previous
relationship i was trying to scare her
off by saying
i'm never going to change who i am based
on a previous release based on
five previous relationships it was based
on every relationship before where i
abandoned myself to try to make one
person happy and create peace in an
environment because there was never
peace
and it's my responsibility is my
decisions by choosing these
relationships by staying and by not
leaving sooner and so it's never because
i just wanted to fix the relationship i
was like okay how can we make this
better what mask have i got to wear
exactly yeah and so
man it's it's
liberating and freeing and the only way
this works
is because
this sounds bad i want to say something
probably sounds bad
i think my girlfriend would be
okay with me saying this but
the only way this works
is i'm willing to walk away at any
moment
i don't want to walk away i want to be
with this woman she's incredible she's a
gift in my life
but if it's not in alignment with her
values her vision her lifestyle
my values my vision my lifestyle and we
don't fully accept who we are then we
shouldn't be together and i want the
best for her and i want the best for me
so as sad as i would be i'm willing to
walk away at any moment if it
compromises
giving up who i am
and
it brings me peace because i'm not
attached
i'm committed
i'm holding it loosely you know i've got
my hands wrapped around the relationship
but i'm not suffocating the relationship
i'm not squeezing it to death i'm like
okay you can
you want it you don't need it yeah i
want it i'm committed i'm all in
but i'm not going to change who i am
yeah to force it
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete and
that has about 100 calories in total
while also giving you 20 grams of
protein
if you haven't tried the keel protein
product do give it a try the salted
caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you
hill for making a product that i
actually like the salted caramel is my
favorite i've got the banana one here
which is the one my girlfriend likes but
for me salted caramel is
the one
when you talk about priorities i was
trying to in my head think of a
a use of words that might be more um
received better and it's funny because i
was thinking about this table i was
thinking there's
this table
now has two levels right the first
foundation of this table you could call
health right without that nothing else
can sit on the table the second
foundation could be mission and then the
relationship sits on top of both and
it's enabled by the foundation of my my
health and my mission absolutely man i
think if you kind of flip it it kind of
sounds better
like because effectively you're putting
your health at the bottom which is yeah
well sources still your foundation but i
completely get that because at any time
in my life where i've abandoned my my
sense of mission
i can only do that for a short period of
time i can only fake that before i start
to lose orientation in my mind and you
resent yourself you represent the person
you present the relationship and you're
like
you're not in love as much with the
relationship because you feel like
you're not it's not lifting you to your
highest calling amen and i think
the beautiful thing about martha in our
relationship
i think should be open with me talking
about this
but every relationship i've been in i
was like i wonder what it would be like
to start therapy in the beginning when
everything is perfect so with martha i
said in the beginning i said listen
i'm doing therapy every two weeks i did
this for the last year on my own
individually i'm going to be doing it
for this next year and years just as
emotional accountability for myself in
life business friends family like
anything i need to process it's just
good for me to clean
the energy
and not let things pile up
and i said i'd love for us and she was
doing this individually i said i'd love
for us to do this together as we start
to develop our relationship when things
are great
and actually see if we are in alignment
and so two weekends ago we did a five
hour session together with my therapist
talking about expectations agreements
values
dreams vision
and just processing anything we needed
to process
and it was such a powerful experience
that
when things are going good to continue
to talk about vision casting what we
want to build together not when things
are going bad and it's really to talk
about things that maybe
we haven't fully been comfortable
talking about yet and putting it out
there
as opposed to hiding things or waiting
for things to come out later
and it was such a powerful five-hour
experience i mean it's very emotional
and you're processing a lot and we're
we're diving in deep exercises eye
gazing talking about things like
it's an emotional
relationship workout yeah you'll save a
lot of time and headache by going to
therapy when things are great as opposed
to when things are bad it's like that
prevention versus reaction
once it's read his ugly head and there's
been some bust up you go to the gym
not because you're sick but because
you're healthy yeah to stay healthy
you know not what not when your weight
to get sick now i need to go to the gym
yeah
and i think who does that in
relationships i don't know anyone who's
done that you hear people say like
before marriage we do like a pre-marital
maybe
relationship training with the churches
or like a therapist but that's after a
few years usually
i just wanted to experiment
i have no idea where it's going to go
but i feel like um something's
something's happening underneath the
surface by both of us doing this
together when things are good men just
don't do this stuff lewis i'm thinking
about my guy friends and i i can imagine
some hesitancy towards them 100 because
they just not it's all the things you've
described they've won a mask of
toughness we put them we keep keep the
emotions in the back room you know what
i mean and and also do you know what you
know what as well guys don't love
conflict with love fun man so they would
probably see
that as oh my god i'm going to get told
off oh my god she's going to give me
[ __ ] for that thing i do it's so hard
man what you've described there that
doing the
making the roots go deeper
again something i have to thank you for
because we had a conversation about
vision values and lifestyle oh and when
i got back from dubai how'd it go
i had a conversation with my girlfriend
and she was all for it so
on that table there and i said i spoke
to louis and he talked about vision
values and lifestyle so we sat there one
night on the weekend
lit a candle we were making some like
pottery stuff and we said after we've
done this we'll just write down our
visions values and lifestyle and we'll
go through them one one by one so like i
speak on one you speak one that's
beautiful it took about three hours and
there were tears oh my god moments of
joy
[Laughter]
but the conclusion was exactly what
you've described there was all these
little things
i'll give you some detail give it to me
how we when we go to sleep at night i
like to go to sleep a certain way so i
like something playing she likes silence
oh but you haven't talked about it
probably hadn't talked about it wow and
it was one of the things just about like
our sleep routine we're obviously gonna
have to sleep in bed for many many years
and we hadn't discussed it and i knew it
was conflict i was getting in bed and
knowing if i play this she's not gonna
be happy but she might not say anything
and so just talking it through and going
look babe the reason why i listen to
something when i go to sleep is because
i've had 29 years of doing that when i
lived in the countryside in plymouth i
had a radio in my room and the kid in me
found comfort in hearing a voice when i
went to sleep you've had 29 years of
doing it another way we've got to ask
ourselves is it really a problem
and we and that was the discussion like
is it a problem if i say if i put an
airport in
because i'm not going to compromise
right and
if you you know you won't even hear it
is it really a problem and then we
discussed why she thought it might be a
problem does that impact her intimacy
well intimacies are suff you know and
eventually we came to this conclusion
and it's not an issue anymore and it was
an issue in our relationship for about a
year it was that niggling little you
could feel the contempt and resentment
slowly building and you guys were a long
distance too right so so it wasn't like
you weren't sleeping it wasn't every
every every day for months no so you
like a couple weeks at a time
yeah but when you're gonna be more
together consistently it could be a
problem yeah that's one of the list of
about 30 things that we
we addressed and worked through and more
than anything coming out the end of that
exercise which is something i've never
done with any partner i've ever had i've
never even had the conversation you just
crash no you don't i didn't learn this
until like two years ago yeah you just
just you just get on with life right you
just
try to keep having fun experiences and
avoid conflict the conflict i've had so
many uncomfortable conversations with
with martha that
it's like a muscle you got to practice
it and every time an uncomfortable
conversation comes up
i have to breathe i'm like oh man i feel
tense yeah i don't want to do it i don't
like it i don't think anyone likes it
but the more we do it here's the thing
we've created a safe space where
and the reason i don't like to do it or
haven't like to do it until now
is because every time i would have an
uncomfortable conversation before the
partner i had could not handle it
so i'd say here's how i'm feeling and
they couldn't handle it or there'd be an
explosion or reaction or something so it
didn't make me feel safe to have the
uncomfortable conversation so i would
avoid it amen and with martha i said to
her listen
like the first one come from a
conversation i go
she asked me a question about something
that was kind of like
i can't remember exactly what it was but
i remember like hmm should i tell her
the truth or should i
cut us a little bit of the truth you
know and i go
do you want me to be 100 honest with you
and she said yes always i go are you
sure you want me to be 100 honest she
said yes and i go okay let me ask you
one more time
and the reason i'm asking is because
i've never met someone who can hold the
space for my honesty
without
reacting or crying or screaming or
running away
so are you saying you're you're
emotionally available to hold the space
for my honesty and truth she said yes
i'm a grown woman i go interesting okay
well here it is
she was like
thank you for your honesty
and it built a
one step okay let me try this again one
more time and make sure she can really
handle it
and the more steps of her holding space
for my honesty my vulnerability and not
exploding or reacting makes me feel like
okay i can say anything and she may not
like it it may be uncomfortable but
she's not explosive and that's a
powerful
thing of how can i
be comfortable in the discomfort while
also feeling safe that's
huge
and you've got to learn to practice that
yourself in a relationship and not be
reactive if a partner is telling you
stuff about their past you don't like or
what they did or this and that you got
to be okay and practice it and they've
got to be and that's where
constantly working on yourself is huge
in intimacy and relationships
and if one person's doing that and the
other person isn't there's going to be
conflict yeah
do you have a trainer when you work out
yes
have you had a business coach in the
past
or mentors
would you stop getting coaching in
business even though you've been so
successful
you want to stop even though you've got
all this money and businesses and
startups and investment
you know dragons then
you'd keep hiring a coach or have a
mentor
in business
why would we not do that for our
emotions and our heart
it is the most powerful
energy that we have emotions and our
heart
and yet
we have a stigma around having a coach
or mentor or a guide or a therapist
whatever you want to call it of
emotional regulation and accountability
and people make so many mistakes in
their lives
by not having that
regulated
their reactions can have consequences
for years
people go to prison for one reaction
people lose their entire business for
one reaction people lose their marriages
because of one emotional reaction
this is one of the most powerful
currencies in the world in my opinion is
having
power over your emotions
not stuffing your emotions not saying
they don't exist not acknowledging them
but expressing them in a healthy
way and in a healthy environment
and when we learn that and i've been
learning that over the last couple of
years it's been an incredible shift in
every area of my life
and i also just feel an incredible sense
of peace i'm not saying that
i'm always going to be perfect in the
future around this
but showing up to someone twice twice a
month
and processing makes me a whole lot
better
you just reminded me of something that
really stuck out to me when i first met
you
was
when we were sat there and you're doing
it again today you've done it three
times today
is
you would say something
and then you'd say
and that's my responsibility
so even when you were talking about
previous relationships you've been and
whatever else
you would not blame the other person you
would like aggressively not blame them
in a in a really remarkable way so you'd
say this happened this happened this
happened this happened
where any other human being i've ever
met was was in their right to attribute
the blame to the person and you would
always end the sentence as you've done
three times today with and that's on me
or and that's my responsibility yeah
why
because i chose it i chose those
experiences i chose those relationships
i chose the environment i chose those
people i chose to stay
and it's my responsibility on how i show
up and how i
react how i respond and how i
stay or leave but even when someone was
toxic or whatever to you you say that
was on me it's my responsibility because
if someone does that
and i stay with them that's on me that's
me not standing up for myself it's me
abandoning myself that's not on them
they're living their life they're doing
what they do naturally
it didn't line up with me
but i stayed so that's on me i can't
expect someone else to change i can't
expect someone else to respect my values
my vision and my lifestyle
they have theirs and they're showing it
through their actions
and their behaviors
and so for me if i'm able to witness
that and be aware and not have the false
sense of love
and be attached to the false sense of
love that i'm feeling i'm having this
feeling about this person and i want to
get back to this healthy environment
with this person
i got to learn to let that go and that's
why i say i can hold love in my hands
loosely
committed and excited about it
but if it's not meant for me i shouldn't
hold on to it and abandon myself and i
think i did that too many times so
that's 100 my responsibility can you run
me through then because i know there's
gonna be people that people listening to
this that i've just had we both done
this exercise and it was amazing and
they're gonna they're now thinking what
is the values part what is the vision
problem what's the lifestyle part yeah i
think the values is really about well
for me the values is like okay
i value health in my life
i'm i'm gonna be focused on my health
i value my mission my team my business
like that's a conscious mission
i value spending time with friends i
value all my hobbies and activities
that's salsa dancing that's traveling
that's all these different things i
enjoy doing
i value
conscious conversations
like i want to have conscious
conversations i can't have superficial
conversations i literally met someone
this morning before i came here
um
who was a part of a big company here in
london
and within two minutes i probably like
shouldn't do this but
i don't know if all british people are
this way and it's not a bad thing but
it's very good with like surface talk
you know oh how was your how was the
flight and uh what was the world order
some
or whatever it is you know and it's like
which is fine but i just can't handle it
after a few minutes so right away i i'm
the person saying next to me
i was like how's your marriage you know
i just i was like how long have you been
married for you know and she was like
i've been married for like six years and
i go
what's three questions you wish you
would have asked i literally did this i
go what's three questions you wish you
would have asked
the day before you got married that you
didn't ask because i'm just fascinated
by people you know i'm curious i'm like
how amazing has marriage been how's it
been has it been healthy have you had
challenges is there anything you wish
you would have changed or talked about
sooner
and right away she's like opening up and
like being vulnerable and i was like
sorry to put this on you right now but
i'm just fascinated
because i want to learn from everyone
and um
so i was like i want to have conscious
conversations it's one of my values so
we have these deep intimate talks all
the time
and so i write down a list of all my
values the vision is this is the vision
for my personal life so personally i
want to be
working out i'm going to be healthy as
an individual my vision is my
my mission which is building a conscious
business to serve millions of people to
help them improve the quality of their
life and this is a major priority to me
this is my one and two priority this is
my vision and also our relationship
vision which i think
is extremely important to talk about
with your partner
here's the vision i have for our
relationship for these
these couple years and for the future
this is what i see
with flexibility nothing's set in stone
but this is what i see what is your
vision for our relationship because
maybe her or his vision is different
one person wants to have kids the other
person doesn't one wants to get married
the other doesn't one wants an open
relationship the other one doesn't want
that one wants their family around every
weekend the other one's like i don't
want to be around your family every
weekend
so what is the vision of our shared
relationship
and then lifestyle i love
you know
traveling do you like to travel
i love to watch these types of movies i
like to eat these types of foods i like
these types of experiences this is a
lifestyle that i live
if you have a completely different
lifestyle that's going to be hard for us
if you like to do none of those things
if you like to stay at home every day
where i want to go out and network with
people and travel
that's just going to be a top we're
going to be butting heads a lot and
there might be
maybe it works but it might cause some
friction and distance in the future so
are we in alignment of values vision and
lifestyle it doesn't have to be 100
perfect but is there alignment in each
category and i think the more alignment
you have
the more potential for a better
healthier relationship
and on things like work this is
obviously a big one for ambitious people
when they um
when they're running a business they're
career driven they're vision or mission
driven and they have a partner
i want to know from a work perspective
what kind of conversation you've had
with martha and vice versa because i
know you're a guy that travels a lot
does a lot of speaking is very you know
in pursuit of yourself and your
potential
so how do you then balance like being a
boyfriend being present going on dates
and stuff what's the
conversation when i first met her i said
one of my values is alone time
like that's one of my values as well is
having
alone time having enough space in our
home so that i can go in the room and do
what i want to do and watch sports or
chill and you can do what you want to do
and i feel like we have space
it doesn't mean i don't want to be
around her all the time but i also value
my space and alone time and so does she
so it's having those conversations
and with with business i said listen if
you can come on any trip like you're
more than welcome to come i'd love for
you to come
but she's doing her own thing she's
traveling as well back and forth from
atlanta so
um and she'll be filming two movies
later this year and gone for two months
at a time so i'll need to travel at
those times and she'll travel with me
and that's the season of our life right
now
and you're anticipating another season
at some point i imagine
at some point yeah i mean it may evolve
may change in the family and all these
other things so it's like when that
season happens
there may be less travel for her how do
you feel about that about what about the
next season that family because there's
a smoke on your face which is why this
is something that i say to her i go
listen i'm really
intentional about building a deep strong
foundation let's keep building a strong
foundation and everything else will
follow
if i feel a sense of peace i feel a
sense of safety in this relationship
just like you
then all these other things are going to
happen naturally and they'll probably
happen fast
naturally once we both have a deeper
foundation and just experienced life
more so have you historically had a
commitment challenge 100 man 100 percent
well actually i haven't had a commitment
challenge because i've always been
committed i've been in very long-term
community relationships
but i've had a commitment challenge in
seeing
around family and kids because i never
trusted the person i was with fully so i
couldn't see myself having kids with
them and i kept
waiting to see something to shift
to where i felt like
this was kind of where my head would go
this is maybe weird but i would say if
something ever happened to me could i
trust this person would take care of my
kids
and i just never felt that because i
never felt like i could trust him with
me like again
i take full responsibility and
accountability because i chose people
that didn't accept me fully that weren't
happy with who i was
and so that's on me
and
i never felt like i could go to the next
level with any of them because i was
like something's off inside and i feel
like
ah i'm changing who i am to make them
happy and they're still not happy
so i can't have kids with i can't see
myself living like this for you know 20
years with someone so
and that kind of trauma that niggle is
is that still inside you there somewhere
as you think about it i think it was in
the first maybe a few months of us
dating
but i don't feel like it is anymore yeah
i feel like every day i create more and
more peace and connection and safety
and she's just an incredible person like
she's just a
great human being and trustworthy and
so it's like even if something happened
to me she could be incredible you know
incredible mom so
of all the things you've learned from
your good and bad relationships if you
were to have if i had to if i said to
you that what is the single biggest
killer of relationships what would your
answer be
uh i would say the biggest killer of
relationships
is being out of integrity with your
authentic power and abandoning yourself
to create peace
in the relationship because
if one person's doing that
or two people are doing that
there's some type of codependency
there's some type of
wound on why we're doing that that's
creating that so for me
the biggest killer is not healing
that's the biggest killer whatever
wounds we have
be on the healing journey it's not it's
not going to happen overnight it's not
like a moment it's a journey of healing
and i think
the more people are willing to dive into
their heart and their emotions
and whatever
insecurities wherever they feel
triggered
that's where you need to lean into
because that trigger's going to come up
into relationships big time if you
haven't healed it so it's the emotional
healing i think it's one of the most
powerful things it's funny i interviewed
a brain surgeon
who'd done over a thousand brain
surgeries and studied the brain and he's
also a
phd in neuroscience so he studies the
mind and thoughts and he's a brain
surgeon
and i said what's the number one skill
do you feel like human beings should
learn to master
and his answer was beautiful he said
emotional regulation
i was like i 100 agree
because if we don't have the power to
regulate
our feelings around a situation and
environment
something that happens in events then
that event has power over us as opposed
to us over that moment
and if it has power over us to where we
react so strongly
we need to ask ourselves why am i so
triggered
where is that one that's a wound
somewhere where is that wound and how
can i start the healing journey i'm not
saying that things are gonna happen in
life and you're never gonna feel
something
but just not react and be overwhelmed
emotionally to where it takes you away
from love and takes you away from your
mission but if something is so strong
that it causes you to lose sleep for
three days or causes you to
react in a negative way it's pulling you
away from
your heart from love and from your
meaningful mission i think we just got
to get back to okay why is this
stressing me out how can i process this
and integrate healing in a healthy way
so that when life happens it doesn't
pull me off my mission
and that's
something i've experienced for the first
time in the last three months is really
like life has happened in a big way for
me
it's
sidetracked me a little bit but it's not
pulling me off like i'm i'm needing to
face it and deal with things and process
but it's not like defeating me to where
i feel like i'm exhausted
and
that's because i'm holding myself
emotionally accountable and doing the
work
if i if someone's listening to this and
they don't have a therapist they don't
have the resources or whatever to have
therapy how else can they go about
developing the self-awareness required
for that emotional regulation journey
there's definitely things you can do on
your own i would i would uh read a book
called how to do the work
by uh nicole lapera which gives you a
lot of exercises and practices and
things like that on how to do the work
yourself so you can get the book for 25
bucks and start there
and start your own ritual and healing
process whether it be journaling whether
it be you know other different types of
meditations things like that they have
she has different rituals in there you
can do
but i would recommend i don't think
there's anything more powerful than
sitting in front of a human and talking
to someone about how you feel or what
you're going through so whether that's a
priest or a parent or a teacher or you
know a friend that you trust
someone you feel like who has a little
bit more wisdom than you
i would start there
until you can afford the therapy
and in terms of emotional journeys
you
cite that you're still on one absolutely
what are the things that you're now
talking to your therapist about that
you're trying to solve in yourself i had
this photo for the last year
i'll just show the camera the photo of
my
five-year-old self and in the last
session i did with her
it was all about um
healing the inner child right it was all
about healing the inner child and doing
the
the work i mean i did some weird stuff
like putting myself in spiritual
and mental environments where i'm
talking
to my five-year-old self and looking at
my five-year-old self hugging my
five-year-old self integrating my
five-year-old self with my adult self
and kind of re-parenting
that psychological child
some weird stuff but
whatever reason it's worked for me
because now i can look at a situation
and say okay do i feel triggered oh
where's that coming from is it from that
hurt child if so all i need to do is
have a conversation with that part of my
mind
and say i'm an adult now and the adult
is here
and i got your back i can take care of
this i know how to process and soothe
things in a healthy way i don't need to
lean onto an addiction or reaction or
whatever it may be to process
i know how to handle this i know how to
breathe i know how to take a walk i know
how to have a conversation and process
you're safe you're okay it's all going
to be okay
whereas before i didn't have that
ability to communicate
with a wounded part of myself
and so now she said we've healed the
five-year-old version of you that was
sexually abused
because i don't get triggered about it i
don't get reactive to it i'm not
defensive and guarded anymore
and i'm also shifting the way i don't
please people in relationships anymore
so i've done a lot of things to do the
work about intimacy and relationships
and just in life
she's like now
and i go okay am i done because this is
a lot of work you know it's like it's a
lot you're diving into your emotions
you're tapping into uncomfortable stuff
you're like crying it's all these things
she's like this is a journey do you want
to go to the next level in your life are
you satisfied i'm like okay you got to
keep going you know there's always
something else
and so she's like we want to tap into
the 11 to 12 year old self and
she's like find a photo that's my next
homework is to put a photo of myself
when i was 11 or 12 and start healing
that part of my life
and there was a bunch of different stuff
that happened in that phase that i
haven't fully healed or forgiven myself
and so that'll be the next work to do
and it'll be like stages of life until i
meet myself to where i am now
interesting and healing and working on
the evolution of all the memories of the
past
that wrote a story and developed
chapters in a book
that did not serve me it's like a script
wasn't it yeah and rewriting the script
and not diminishing the things that
happened
but acknowledging them and healing them
in a different way and processing it in
a healthy way
so that i can meet myself where i'm at
now
and then really start elevating how much
has
doing a podcast
where you sit with these people but also
yeah right it's a game changer when i
get the biggest like neuroscience i've
had so many and this year has been like
the year of therapists and
neuroscientists and spiritual gurus and
just being like
figuring out more and more
about emotions about regulation about
healing about inner child work because
i have people on there i'm like when i'm
struggling with something in my life i
bring those people on i'm like teach me
how to like overcome this
right it's incredible yeah and so my
audience would be like oh louis is going
through stuff with this oh louis is
going through a breakout oh lewis is in
a relationship
it's amazing the other thing that i am i
know a lot of people will
will struggle with is the confidence to
overcome some kind of fear you talked a
little bit there about ourselves story
and how that limits us one of the the
fears i know you had in your life which
is almost impossible to imagine based on
the man you are sat in front of me today
was that fear of public speaking huge
fear man and i could not stand in front
of
two to three p friends in school
and really even have a conversation like
i didn't know how if someone asked me a
question i would get nervous i couldn't
even respond with really
a small story just because i was so
the story i told myself that i was so
used to being made fun of and picked on
growing up
that i just didn't want to speak that
much because i didn't want to be made
fun of
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as you might
know crafted are one of the sponsors of
this podcast and crafted are a jewelry
brand and they make really meaningful
pieces of jewelry the really wonderful
thing about crafted jewelry is it's
super affordable it looks amazing the
pieces hold tremendous meaning and they
are really well made i think i've worn
this piece for almost a year
it hasn't broken hasn't changed color
because it's really really good quality
and it costs roughly 50 quid people will
be surprised when they hear that they'll
probably assume that all of my jewelry
is like solid gold and cost thousands
and thousands of pounds but what's the
point when you can achieve the exact
same effect from a piece of jewelry
that's high quality and cost 50 quid
that's why i buy crafted to put in
context of where you are today you're an
international speaker you're getting
honest you're getting paid big six
figure numbers to speak once yeah and i
just want to put that in context because
you went from someone that basically
couldn't have a conversation
kind of like an international public
speaker yeah i don't know if um
it was like this in school in the uk but
in america at least in ohio where i grew
up the teacher would sometimes say okay
we're gonna have you guys read aloud
right and okay lewis open up chapter one
paragraph one and stand up and read in
front of people
and it got to the point where
it was so terrifying because i would get
up and i was not able to read until
really about 10th grade no joke when i
went into eighth grade that private
boarding school they tested me
reading and comprehension and everything
and i had a second grade reading level
so when i was in school
it was so hard for me to stand in front
of the class and read aloud because
the simplest words i didn't know what
they were what they were
dyslexic so it was just challenging to
read and then i'd feel nervous and then
i would sabotage it and then kids would
laugh because i couldn't read
and so it's just kind of like a
traumatizing thing that i had to learn
how to let go of and heal
and so i just never wanted to speak in
front of people
and i remember
this is funny i was also
um i was also terrified to dance
and i started salsa dancing obsessively
because i wanted to overcome this fear
and when i was learning this skill of
salsa dancing to overcome that fear i
met a guy who was a public speaker and
he got paid to speak around the country
and i said
how do you do this and he said meet me
tomorrow at this coffee shop and all and
i'll answer any question you have
because we're literally like in the
middle of the dance floor and i'm asking
this
so i meet him at this coffee shop in
columbus ohio
and
he was like if you want to overcome the
fear of public speaking you need to
practice it every week and i recommend
joining this thing called toastmasters
where you can practice in a safe
environment where they're not going to
laugh at you
and he said go every week for a year
and come back to me when you're done
and that's what i did i went to a
toastmasters club every week for a year
and i remember it was terrifying for the
first few months
but the more i did it and just messed up
i just kept messing up but i found
someone to mentor me there i practiced
it consistently every single week my
next speech
i would put myself in uncomfortable
conversations to just be
made fun of or just feel like i'm so
stupid around these people but every
week i'd show up i'd get a little bit
more confidence a little bit more
confidence to the last
week of the year
i remember
i had no notes no props no nothing
and i was extremely poised and confident
and got like the standing ovation at the
end of the year because they saw my
journey the first speech i had
everything written out word for word
word for word i look down at behind a
podium and read word for word i didn't
look up once on my first speech
to the point where i was like okay i'm
writing a speech and then looking up a
couple times while reading it to then it
was like just note cards then it was
bullet points so then it was a slide to
then it was nothing
but it was
mind-blowing because it took a year to
kind of get a baseline of confidence
and it took every week showing up but
i'm telling you if i could do something
like this it's possible but
you got to be willing to be so
uncomfortable to overcome these fears
sometimes
there's two things i was reflecting on
as you were speaking then it's the first
is how that you know repetitions
rewrites this new kind of subjective
evidence about who we are what we're
capable of which results in mastery but
it starts with repetition which creates
new evidence and then you've got the
mastery point but also just that that
wasn't just a lesson about public
speaking it's a general lesson about
what happens when in life we arrive at
the crossroads of fear and one side says
turn right to go back to comfort which
is never do this thing ever again
because it's humiliating and the other
is like it's the lights are off down
that path but it's like into the fear
and this happens every week in
everyone's life
in your job in your relationship in
someone offers you oh do you want to
come and do this thing and you go that's
not south sudan's
and or you go through a hard
relationship and you're like i can't
open my heart up exactly love
vulnerability um but so evident in your
story and even the fact that you write
down your biggest fears every year
it's so clear that you continually chose
to go into the fear and that resulted in
tremendous growth yeah
it's always it's always and
the amount of confidence i have over the
last 15 20 years really of just taking
on these different fears that i thought
i would never be able to do
let's talk salsa dancing you know i
started that 17 years ago it's opened up
a world to me i've traveled the world
i've salsa dance in every major city
around the world over the last 17 years
i've met incredible people
i have had so much fun i get to just go
and dance and have fun
and it gives me an incredible sense it's
a tool that i can take out at any moment
whenever needed it's a language that i
can speak to so many people that speak
that language
and it's given me a level of confidence
that i never had without that because it
was a fear and now it's something that's
fun that i've mastered it's incredible
same thing with public speaking
i remember
thinking
before i started toastmasters like if i
want to get a job i need to learn public
speaking if i want to like improve in
the career that i go into i need to be
able to communicate in a board room and
get my ideas across
even if i'm an employee i just need to
be able to communicate or if i'm a ceo
one day i need to be able to inspire if
i want to be on stage i need to be able
to get a message across to influence and
impact people so i was like if i want to
accomplish my dreams i need to overcome
this fear and
it's brought me so many opportunities
because i spent a year obsessing over
this and failing
again it's brought me incredible
financial resources it's put me in front
it's i've traveled the world because of
speaking it's brought me business deals
i've met and collaborated with other
speakers that i've met on stage at these
events
it's given me confidence you know by
having this skill
so every fear that i have
if i master it and i go all in on it
something magical and beautiful happens
on the other side same in relationships
after the previous relationship i was
like okay
i can be afraid and be single for a year
and like guard my heart
or i can open my heart
keep it expansive not closed off after
this pain and challenge keep it open and
see what's possible
and when i met her i was thinking to
myself ah i don't know if i want to like
go into this but i was like let me keep
it open and explore
and it's been magic and beauty on the
other side because i've gone on that as
well
every time it's just something magical
happens
when i think about that crossroads
analogy where you've got you arrive at
the crossroads of fear and it says turn
right if you want to go back into
certain comfort oh turn left it's dark
in there yeah it goes go into the fear
and address it went through it i think
the people the reason why people turn
right into certainty and to comfort or
really go back right is because they've
miscalculated
what the actual risk is
so in the case of say being vulnerable
in your relationships
it seems like the the low risk path is
to like keep the mask on just please
them and whatever yeah however when you
zoom out that is the existential risk of
the relationship is faking and being
inauthentic to yourself that was
actually the risk but people like they
mis they don't know what the risk is and
generally in life it's people when they
say to me oh you're so courageous for
dropping out of university and starting
this business i've reflected on that
over the years because i've really
struggled with this concept of people
thinking i was courageous
in my mind the risk was staying in
university going into the corporate rat
race and not pursuing myself and then
having a mid-life crisis when i'd
abandoned myself that was the risk the
easy cowardice thing to do was leaving
university and pursuing myself and i
think the refraining of it yeah is
really probably the most potent way of
getting people to understand that in
fact the dark
left side of that fear crossroads is
actually the least risky path to take if
you zoom out absolutely and you see
what's on the other side yeah what's
possible for you what's available on the
other side yeah exactly or even if you
see what certainty and comfort will
exactly deliver
it's about having a short period of pain
versus long period of pain and the short
pain is diving into the fear
maybe the pain is a week a month or a
year in order to overcome that fear
until you overcome it and transcend it
or having this numbing low-level pain
for the rest of your life by not
choosing that
which one do you want
you know for me i just can't live that
way and it's not just a one right so if
you if you if you fake it in work and
then your relationships then your
friendships then you're gonna have in
your health
yes you're gonna have ten loans exactly
which is gonna what happens then
depression yeah crippling anxiety
exactly panic attacks
behavior all these you know
addictions everything man as you look
off into your future then lewis
you're thinking about how lewis house
shapes his future what he's pursuing how
he finds his meaning and happiness on an
ongoing basis what is the answer
everything is based on mission the the
mechanism
is kind of irrelevant how i do it is
irrelevant the mission is to serve 100
million lives weekly to help them
improve the quality of their life
that's the mission that's your mission
that's the mission that's been the
mission for about eight years it's been
consistently that why 100 million
people ask me that i think when i came
up with that number
it's because i'd already impacted
millions at the time
and whenever i ask people like what's
your dream and they say they want to
change the world it just doesn't seem
real like okay what does that mean
and then some people say i want to
change
billions of lives okay
it just seems like it's hard to measure
it's hard to measure that quickly like
how fast is that going to happen but i'd
already impacted millions and i was like
okay what would it look like how long
would it take me to reach 100 million
people
at once like in a year
and then how could i what would it look
like to do it in a month and then in a
week and then how could i repeat that
every week
what's the mechanism right now it's
podcasting youtube social media books
events all those different things maybe
in the future there's another mechanism
for me i'm not attached to the mechanism
i'm committed to the mission
and so
i'm flexible and open on how
i want to make sure that i'm a
a messenger
and i'm a facilitator of messages with
other messengers
and that's the mission for this season
of my life
until something shifts inside of me
where it says you know that's not your
calling anymore then i'll listen to that
next mission
two questions then the first question is
why does that matter to you why does
helping 100 million lives a week matter
to you
what are you going to get if that
happens if you succeed well helping one
person matters to me when i wrote my
book the mask of masculinity i remember
thinking to myself
this probably isn't going to sell 100
million copies right it's about how men
can be vulnerable like most men don't
want to buy that book it's this one here
yeah so the mask of masculinity
i
once i started opening up about my
healing journey and seeing the impact
and the responses that men were having
i was like
gosh i need to write about this don't i
internally i was like this needs to
happen next my book agent was like let's
go do another book about business or
marketing and i was like
i just can't do it like even if i make
no money
this has to come out of me
because if we can help one man heal
their internal relationship with
themselves and then heal their
relationship with their family and their
marriage whatever it might be then it's
worth it to me
and so i just felt like i needed to put
it out
and
so i'm happy to help one person and i
feel accomplished i feel
purposeful useful i feel like my talents
were for something meaningful
but i know there's something more inside
of me and so i'm striving
to serve 100 million lives one of the
reasons that's meaningful to me is
because i believe that we're all here
for a reason i believe that we all have
a certain unique set of gifts and
talents
and i want to see how far those talents
can spread i just feel like that's part
of my calling at this season of my life
and
i'm a hundred percent
happy and fulfilled with all the efforts
i've had to this moment because it's
everything i've been able to do
but i know there's so much more so this
is just something for me to aim towards
to reach towards it gives me a target
it's something i can measure it's not
too unrealistic it's a big number but i
feel like yeah how things are going
maybe it could happen in a year maybe
it's 10 years i don't know
but it gives me a focus and it keeps me
in alignment on
the things i say yes and no to
does this decision project
interview
partnership serve 100 million lives or
get me closer to it
or is it a distraction so it helps me
get clear on saying yes or no to things
as well and what happens today if you
get an email when you leave here and it
says lewis good news we've we've we're
now reaching 100 million lives a week
i say great we gotta we gotta repeat
this over and over again for a while
until i feel like okay what's the next
goal
i mean i mean if we get 100 million
lives weekly
then i'll be like awesome it's been i'm
doing this podcast for nine years now
it's like i've been doing this for a
long time
last year we got over 100 million views
just on our youtube channel alone so
we're in the hundreds of millions a year
of and i don't calculate it as like a
like or like a one second view i'm like
what's a 20 minutes of some an
interaction we had over 100 million just
on youtube of 24 minute watch time so
for me that's a deep encounter of
someone
introspective learning diving in you
know overcoming something and trying
something new that's meaningful to me
and so if we can do that weekly for a
while
then i'll i'll take an assessment and
say okay where am i at my life this
season
am i striving for more am i maintaining
am i
shifting you know i'll reassess it then
would it be a really happy day i'm happy
today
i'm really happy today because gary
vaynerchuk said to me he said my goal is
to buy the new york jets and in the same
breath he said it will be the worst day
of my life right because there's no more
chase it's no more thing to work towards
and here's the thing i'm happy today
because i have inner peace and i think
there's no goal that i've accomplished
in the past that has brought me into
peace when i accomplished it i felt
depressed and anxious with a lot of
goals from the past
now i feel happy with just showing up
and giving my best day to day it's as
lame as that sounds
the healing work has allowed me it
doesn't mean i'm like satisfied i still
am driven and i'm hungry for more
but i'm just in such a beautiful place
in my relationship with myself and my
relationship with martha and my
relationship with friends and family my
team i just feel like man
if this was it i'm in a peaceful place
and that's beautiful
amazing and i i truly feel it i truly
feel it in everything that you said yeah
and it doesn't mean i'm perfect and it
doesn't mean i have it all figured out
it doesn't mean i'm not going to make
mistakes in the future
it just means
that's the path of one
we have a closing tradition on this
product okay which is the previous guest
writes a question for the next guest
into the diary
what is the most frequent piece of
advice people ask you for and what is
the answer
i mean
what do people ask me for what is the
most frequent
piece of advice people ask you like the
question they ask me for like a piece of
advice yeah what's the most frequent
piece of advice i mean it's like what
would you do if you were starting all
over again you know if you were 21 and
or you started your podcast again or you
know you were getting started again in
your business
what would you have done differently
is what i get asked
and then what's the answer i mean the
answer is
i don't know if i would have done
anything differently
because it's all given me a lot of
wisdom and experiences to where i'm at
now
i wish i would i guess i wish i would
have like known this stuff sooner but i
think we all need to learn things as
they come to us
what i will i guess what i wish i'd
known differently is how to have inner
peace
i wish i would have had that skill
because i think i would be farther ahead
and i would have been happier sooner
inside
had i learned that skill
of healing of inner peace emotional
regulation all these things that kind of
held me back
from
being 100 my authentic self and in my
power towards building everything that
i'm doing
i sit here with people a lot and i
remember speaking to gary and
gary talked to me about the importance
for him of legacy yeah is this something
that's important to you the concept of
legacy does it take yes and no it is in
the sense that
like with my dad passing
i think about his legacy right
and i've had a lot of
like sad moments and i've also had a lot
of beautiful grateful moments thinking
about his life
and
his legacy
and what he
how he lived what he taught during his
his life and what he left behind in
terms of wisdom and lessons
and i think it's important to
for me
that's valuable
in the sense that
i'm going to be around
you know my siblings going to be around
his grandchildren are around who
experienced him
they're going to have
we are going to have memories and an
imprint based on his life and how he
lived
with us
and now it's all about how we show up
through his legacy you know i'm a part
of his legacy he was a part of my
foundation and now i'm going to be a
part of that and i think about that
because i want to make sure that my last
name
is meaningful and it would make him
proud
you know to make sure that am i doing
things in alignment with what he taught
me
would make
the world a better place would be good
for our community am i living to the
highest level of the values not the
stuff that he didn't do well but the
stuff he did well do well
and so i think it's important because
we're going to be
interacting with people and when we're
gone
they're either think of us in a positive
way or negative way and they might be
acting
like we acted in either of those ways
so i think it's valuable and important
and i think about it in that sense but i
also think about that it's not important
because in 200 years no one's going to
remember
maybe you know like someone has like a
memory of in a history book and they
talk about you
but no one you know is going to know you
in a in a hundred years
no one you interact with is going to
know you so and the the big
scheme of things you know
it doesn't it doesn't matter after a
hundred years really
but it matters because everything is
a reflection of our past
it's like dominance yeah my grandparents
influence
my parents
their traumas and their beauty
influenced them which influenced me and
i felt like i had to
heal the traumas of the past legacy as
well
just like i'm carrying with me the
beautiful parts of the past
and and leaning into those but also
healing things that were brought down
that they never healed
so there's an impact with the legacy
yeah
i my answer is very similar to yours in
the sense that i i've never understood
why people care about
what people like what people will say
about me when i'm gone right right like
i don't care because i again if i
engaged in that thinking it's the same
as caring too much about what they think
about me now yeah like i'm not gonna be
there i'm gonna be dead so but i i've
never heard it and it's really
refreshing to hear that kind of domino's
analogy where like actually the way that
i the way that i show up is going to
impact my kids they might impact 10 then
it's 20 that's 50 and then that's how
the world is created yeah and i think
the traumas that our parents
you know had or didn't heal are going to
be felt in our childhood in our
adulthood until we heal it
so
and that might be their grandparents and
their grandparents who'd like pass it
down so we either need to
heal it now otherwise we're going to
pass it down to our kids
lewis thank you
um you're a very very special individual
for so many reasons but i think having
had this conversation with you the the
most and also you know it's a reflection
of your book as well the mask of
masculinity is your ability to be open
and vulnerable is i think like the most
powerful service especially men can be
doing in this world for all the reasons
we've described because that like being
emotionally in touch and being willing
to be open is the foundation of all of
our interactions our happiness our
mental health our even our physical
health and as as is the case in this
country at the moment the thing that is
unfortunately killing most men under the
age of 45 is themselves
suicide is the biggest killer of men in
in our country under that age group so
and it's a reflection of i think
the lack of um
vulnerability absolutely and the lack of
openness and the lack of
ability to process and regulate our
emotions so
having a light like you in the world
that is leading that crusade in such an
open way even though i know the feeling
of discomfort it can even gives me to
talk about things like my mental health
or how i'm feeling or all those things
inspires me and you've inspired me to be
more open and in fact you've actually
inspired me to go on the journey of like
having therapy just for the sake of
not because there's i'm like oh i need
to fix this but because of the
prevention and because of all the
unknown unknowns absolutely man so thank
you thank you you're an inspiration to
me and so many others and it's been a
joy to have you on my podcast thanks
brother appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]